Certain amino acids like glycine and methyl B vitamins are needed in order for the body
to detoxify. Since I have to be a low animal protein and have no methyl groups, also I
have a, when the person said I am MTHFR, that means they have MTHFR, a genetic defect,
I felt that I had a fully reductase gene defect. It seems I am not able to detox the way
I should. Can I use some kind of amino supplement to help with this? Yes, you can use protein
supplements. That's why we have a protein powder through US enzymes. That's low in glutamine
that we recommend that you feel like you're low in amino acids. Should I do a cheek swab to
know a little bit more about the B vitamins? You can, but you could start simply with
trying the US enzymes, proteinzyme, and see if that makes a difference with you. And again,
with cancer patients, the only cancer patients that I recommend go on a methyl supplement,
methylated supplements are those that maybe have high full of cystic levels. So,
getting a blood test and getting your whole cystic levels checked, maybe a good thing to do.
You said proteinzyme is good, it contains kale, is that a problem? No, it doesn't contain two high
levels, so it's not a problem. So it's okay. Remember, you're, you're not, you're not gonna ever
eliminate, you know, nitric oxide sources in foods. I mean, I want you to eat green leafy vegetables
and you're eating some spinach, but I just don't want you to have a kale shake.